the longest living goldfish on record
was 43 years old but chances are your
goldfish didn't even live a quarter that
long
in fact most goldfish don't survive past
their fifth birthday and that's a major
problem since they're supposed to live
for about as long as your cat so why are
goldfish dying so young
the usual culprit behind your goldfish
is untimely demise is well poop
you see goldfish waste contains toxins
like ammonia that can burn gills and
even damage the brain in the wild this
isn't a problem freshwater lakes and
ponds are home to armies of bacteria
that break it down into less harmful
chemicals but in your home tank there's
no bacteria to be found you have to
introduce it and that's where a lot of
goldfish owners slip up because you
can't just buy a fish the same day you
get your tank the process of growing
bacteria takes patience first you'll
need to remove chlorine from your tank
water using a conditioner chlorinated
tap water is fine for you to drink since
it kills off germs but it's not so great
for the bacteria you want to cultivate
once you've created a safe space for the
bacteria to grow they'll come from all
over the air the outside of the tank and
any rocks or plants you stick in the
tank for decoration you can also buy
commercially sold bacterial cultures
grown in labs after that all they need
is dinner fish food will do as the food
breaks down it releases ammonia for the
bacteria to eat and finally you wait for
a while
depending on how much bacteria you start
with the process can take about two
months that's right two months but then
there should be enough bacteria you can
double-check with a simple water test
kit but here's the thing
all the bacteria in the world won't keep
your fish alive if the tank is too small
you see as these bacteria gobble up
goldfish poop they produce some waste of
their own and if it's not sufficiently
diluted it can kill your goldfish a
dinky single gallon bowl is much too
small and even the 10 gallon tank you
see in every pet store won't cut it a
single adult goldfish needs at least
twice that much water to thrive that's
almost 40 kilograms of water 2,000 times
heavier than your goldfish and even with
a huge tank you'll still need to replace
about 30% of the water every two weeks
because besides poop goldfish release
hormones and pheromones into their
environment which if left unchecked can
stop their growth that might help
explain why goldfish and healthy
environments can reach the size of an
American football while your last
goldfish wasn't much bigger than your
index finger once you have a big
detoxified tank Goldie just needs one
more thing your attention because you're
not swimming in the tank with her it's
hard to notice if something's wrong with
say the water quality so oftentimes new
goldfish owners don't realize anything's
amiss until it's too late and common
diseases like fin rot white spot disease
and fungal infections have already taken
hold so it's a good idea to pay careful
attention to how the water looks and
smells and anyway spending time with
your goldfish will be worth it since you
can teach Goldie to swim through hoops
and eat from your hand
you